what kind of um
what what what awakened you what what
what brought the the red pill awareness
to you uh as far as um
you know changing your whole outlook on
life and just realizing that these
uncomfortable truths
that was that was late in life for me it
was uh because i was
38 39 or so when i got divorced it was
definitely late late 30s
started dating right away uh
then got involved in a three-year ltr
with a single mommy with two kids which
was a total
like mess and that's what red pilled me
was that that was like i was around 43
and i'm like
this is this is messed up like i was
just i was
it was like my entire life i was just
looking back at it at like 43 and i'm
like how is it that women
are not what i've been told that they're
supposed to be that are not sugar and
spice and all things nice
they don't behave in a way that's you
know congruent with all the disney
movies that i've consumed my entire life
there's just like one thing after
another it's like it was like dominoes
started to fall and it was like you just
had to follow the entire path the
dominoes kind of like leading down
i'll tell you where it all started for
me i was on a men's retreat with a bunch
of guys and i was talking to this guy
tom who uh
who was the guy that introduced me to um
you know the red pill with the rational
mail
and you know we're just shooting a [ __ ]
about relationships and he's like dude
you really gotta
like read rolo tomasi's book the
rational mailing i'm like all right done
oh
you know it's i'll take whatever
recommendation you got because i'm out
of my own [ __ ] right now like i'm out of
my own materials so what do you got
right yeah
yeah and um you know i downloaded the
audiobook and i listened to it on the
flight back i was i was in spokane
washington we were at this um
guys thing there's about 30 guys at ben
greenfield's house and we're doing this
biohack and all this kind of cool [ __ ]
but
yeah like i listened to this thing on
the flight back and uh i was just like
wow that was that was deep i gotta i
gotta go through that again and i went
through the book like two or three times
before i even started talking about it
but even but even prior to that like i
was still talking about
some relationship stuff on my channel i
remember somebody once said about six or
12 months prior to that they're like you
should do
a video on the kind of women to avoid
dating that was kind of a red pill video
before i was even red pill
oh okay i didn't know that yeah i didn't
know this so you were you were putting
out like that type of content before you
actually like fully awakened
yeah like i started to see you know the
reality of certain behaviors and i was
like
okay there's a consistent pattern to be
like if you date single moms which
you're gonna end up doing if you get
divorced at 39 you don't know [ __ ] like
i did
then you're going to go out with enough
of them to be like okay there's a
consistent pattern here of some
serious bs i'm just firing at the blocks
i'll go ahead
okay yeah there's like a consistent
pattern of some serious bs here that i
gotta
that i gotta get some clarity on it's
like you know making some clips on that
which really seemed to resonate well
with a lot of guys
that was just the start like that was a
catalyst for me you know what i mean are
you still muted bro
yeah no i'm here i'm here uh no what i
was going to say was so that
so the single mom experience is really
what what red what year was this was
this around 2015
2016 uh i don't know that
we we split up 2015 that was about five
years ago i think
um okay okay and i guess
uh and we'll go live in five seconds and
we're gonna fire up the
phone lines here guys um i will take the
phone calls later on
you know what i mean but uh i'm just
firing them up now
but anyway so like i was saying
uh so you read the book and you went
over it like four or five times and it's
crazy man cuz like when guys
because i have a friend here uh in miami
and and what red pulled him was also a
single mom and
he got it through tom lycus and he
looked to tom lycus
he listened to one of his broadcasts
like three times in a row it's like when
you get the information it's like
what and then you like listen to it
again and again and again you're like oh
my
god and it's like it's like this this
moment because
because even like for me i grew up in a
you know
uh arab muslim household so i had always
kind of like known these truths because
my parents had talked about it even my
mom would tell me these these
truths and i always was like what are
you guys talking about and then it
wasn't into
until i like went out into the world and
i saw how things really operate that i
was like oh
this is why they told me to do things
like this or whatever it may be
um so that's very uh very interesting
so so you were with the girl for about
five years
you change your outlook so like what
changed when you when you finally like
uh took the pill and you you went on
about your life like did you just
have you just been like i'm not gonna uh
date
a long-term relationship wise never live
with a woman like did you you live with
this woman and everything like that
no no no we were and it wasn't five
years it was only three
um we split up in uh 2015 so that so
that was five years ago but
um you know there was like talk of like
uh living together
and she was talking about marriage and
[ __ ] like that i remember like early on
um she brought up like marriage like
within the first six or seven months i'm
like
um this is like before i you know was a
wick i'm like look
i've got my [ __ ] sorted out i got a kid
from a prior marriage i need to make
sure that my
estate is dispersed to where it needs to
go a prenup would need to be in place
before i'd even consider that
and she lost her [ __ ] right like right
away so that's one of the tests that you
got to use with women
is the prenup talk um you know when it
comes to veteran
and getting through the red flags
because if she's going to lose her [ __ ]
over you saying i want to protect my
assets and make sure my kids get what's
you know deserve it of them rather than
giving it away to somebody else's kids
or somebody else's life
um and they lose their mind over it
that's a pretty good indicator that
you've got some problems coming your way
um but yeah you know there was talk of
blending fan
dude i didn't even know what the hell
blending families was she kept saying
this word blending families
this is this is so bizarre why would i
want to blend like put my family in a
blender and blend it up with yours like
yeah you know like invite your crap and
mix it up with my stuff
but yeah it's it's it's really bizarre
man a lot of guys get
get get super caught up in it like a lot
of guys just get sucked in the vortex i
mean
one of the biggest problems that that
guys choose to
invite into their lives when i'm doing
my coaching sessions with guys
like when i do consults is they get
wound up with single mommies
like bizarre how they'll how they'll put
them up on a pedestal
like worship them and you know in all
fairness like i was kind of there myself
too right
but when you react like when you realize
who you are what your worth is man and
how your value has continued to go up
over time if you've done the work on
yourself obviously
and women as time goes on you know past
the ages their early 20s
their value goes down there's a total
disconnect and a lot of guys don't
realize that their value is considerably
higher or it should be higher than what
it is
and they should hold themselves to
higher standards and have some dignity
about the women that they're going to
invite in their lives but a lot of guys
don't they're just like oh you know i
can get scraps over here good let's go
right yeah and and you know rich i'm
really glad you brought that up because
uh that's how actually i discovered your
content i remember the first video i saw
of yours this was
man like maybe almost two years ago now
was the was the smv
video where you had the chart and then
you talked about how uh a man's value
like
you know as he gets older it goes up
while a woman simultaneously declines
and then you guys intersect right around
that 30 years old and that's when she's
trying to
you know lock you down because women
know on and like an innate level that
um their values derive from their looks
and youth and youth is a big part of
that
and obviously they have a biological
time clock as well and that was kind of
like an eye opener like oh wow like men
we don't adhere
to the same mating timeline that women
want you know what i'm saying like if
nobody tells guys this mark nobody
nobody will sit a man down in his in in
his
19th year and say men this is what you
need to know
about your value and at the same token
most guys won't even want to hear it i
mean if you try to sit most guys down i
bet you nine out of ten guys
it'll be like in one in one ear and out
the other
and they'll go chasing becky down the
road putting her up on a pedestal
it's really only until they get older
and they've and they've matured and they
really see like
how bad choices can really affect them
and erode their opportunities in life
that they
take [ __ ] seriously yeah that was one of
the biggest truth bombs i i remember i
shared that video with so many of my
friends rich like i was just like
what like because like in my head i was
like this is so true because
girls are always angling for some type
of exclusivity with you
as soon as they get older you know what
i'm saying and that's when you're
getting older your money's starting to
finally come in and you're starting to
do well
and i can't tell you how many guys i
know men like uh that got married in
their late twenties
to a girl that they went to school with
and in my head i'm like you guys are
idiots because
your values just trying to increase you
know whereas like if you had asked that
girl 10 years prior
when she was 19 20 hey you want to get
married she would say hell no because
she wants she's enjoying her time so
like nowadays when even when i advise
guys on console consultations whatever i
tell them
never adhere to a woman's dating
timeline if she tries to pressure you
into like
marriage or anything like that never
enter her frame ever ever ever
ever it's it's it's always got to be she
has to
she has to compliment your life and
enter your frame otherwise
you're setting yourself up from from the
get-go for a very very bad
experience
you